durant deux jours 140 agents de voyages
ont parcouru l'alsace 140 agents de
voyage venus du monde entier une visite
prélude au salon mondial du tourisme et
des voyages qui ouvre ses portes à la
fin de la semaine à paris eric as luke
savage n'allait pas les compter ils sont
exactement 140 140 agents de voyage
venus de 20 pays du bout du monde asie
amérique océanie et afrique
après la bourgogne l'an passé ils ont
été conviés par la direction du tourisme
à découvrir l'alsace dans le cadre d'une
opération baptisée rendez-vous france
1986 strasbourg colmar et mulhouse en
deux jours avec en prime la route des
vins une visite menée au pas de charge
pour ces tours opérateurs globalement
séduit par les multiples attraits de
l'alsace c'est très différent des sites
touristiques de l'inde ici c'est une
région unique pour son architecture la
cathédrale que nous avons vu en est le
meilleur exemple
je pense que l'aspect historique de
cette région est très intéressante
de même que l'aspect industriel car
c'est très différent de l'australie les
japonais c'est la région du 28 mai ils
connaissent aussi l'alsace pour son
industrie comme celle de l'allemagne de
la france
l'alsace est connu en inde
elle a vraiment mais je m'y emploierai
dès mon retour
fear est ce que l'on peut espérer voir
bientôt ici les premiers tours essai
australien
oui j'en suis sur mes collègues et moi
même qui sommes ici allons inciter nos
compatriotes à venir en alsace et je
suis sûr qu'ils en seront très heureux
générer un moyen terme de nouveaux
courants touristiques vers la france et
en particulier vers l'alsace
tel est l'objectif de cette opération si
le tourisme est aujourd'hui un des
points forts de notre balance
commerciale
il ne faut cependant pas négliger de lui
offrir sans cesse de nouveaux débouchés
car là aussi la concurrence est
particulièrement rude